the Joe Rogan experience a lot of people
I've talked to exactly what you're
talking you're mentioning and they did
do a heroic journey yeah and they then
look back and go on why was i
prioritizing that yeah I want to be out
with my children yes you know and
looking at birds or walking in nature
yeah nature like I might one of my books
else I have mushrooms of the world has a
great chapter and I think called good
tips for great trips and one of the
things I understand the clinically
controlled settings for clinical studies
etc a lot of us don't need that but I
really enjoy being on the ocean Bluff or
a high point and by being in the
mushrooms about a half an hour before
sunset being with a loved one also good
to have an experienced person who's not
tripping who is up the watcher sitter a
sitter a sitter is there thinking
meditation practice in place folks give
these people some space who's just
watching and then the people who are in
vibing understand they have a watcher
they have somebody who's anchored who
could help them and then to have this
the Sun go down and and the stars come
out and the colors and then this oceanic
expanse of experience is just as nothing
short of spiritual and I'd agree I think
there's one thing we should talk about
though there are people that have a
tendency toward schizophrenia and these
people have sometimes they have
psychedelic breaks like they'll have
psychedelic experiences and then they
don't do well they well you brought that
up and that is a D selection from the
from the clinical studies of candidates
who want to engage but my good friend
Mark Hayden who runs Maps Canada had a
very interesting story with the
schizophrenic I mean he also cautioned
in every physician I know is on the same
page as you
including medic medical marijuana edible
edible marijuana seems to have a
significant effect on people with it
what
mark noted with this one person who is a
severe schizophrenic was that he still
heard voices in his head but the voices
now were friendly they were affirming
they weren't like you know somebody like
you know you are a good person right and
so he still had the voice in the head
but the tenor and tone and attitude of
the voices were supportive what I'm
talking about is it bringing on these
schizophrenic experiences that there has
been some evidence particularly about
marijuana that high doses of marijuana
for people that have tendencies and we
don't know right what what causes
someone to have schizophrenic breaks
because there there is a difference
between pre and post right people have
had deteriorating mental health that's
it correlates with schizophrenia like
what what it what it caused them to be
less gets a frantic or not exhibiting
any of the the problems and then all the
sudden having severe problems post
psychedelic trip or post large dose
edible marijuana and or even large dose
smoking it Oh some people they dab and
they smoke wax and then it happens to
people that smoke too much pot there's
certain people that have that tendency I
I would defer to clinicians who are
extremely skilled in this area and who
have seen many many patients I'm not a
doctor but I concur with you I think
that is a real concern the difference
between a toxin and a drug oftentimes be
dose and at lower doses you could see
things at the higher doses you you don't
right
so it's an entire spectrum and it's so
complex and individuality zuv of people
are so uniquely different yeah I have a
friend who's a doctor if he smokes a
joint he can't go to sleep high smoke a
joint
and I'm a-comin to a cuddle puddle man
I'm ready for the pillow you know at
night I just I use it for going to sleep
yeah I'm the opposite yeah I start
writing I want to read I want to watch
documentaries but it's a sativa thing
too as well right isn't it do you have a
significant difference in the way your
body responds sativas versus indicas I
like to be educated
subject I've used both for a very long
time
I love Afghani indica I you have a beard
I have a beard I love the smell of
cannabis on my leg or smelling you beer
yeah you weirdo it's my perfume right I
get it so but there's a lot you know
we're in a new realm of pharmacology mmm
and Pharma cognizant and this and I
think we have to navigate this carefully
the problem with natural products is how
do you standardize them to the active
constituent when you have more than one
active constituent you know how do you
standardize them all there's an
entourage or a symphony effect this
speaks to the complexity of nature but I
have a phrase that I like is don't let
the perfect be the enemy of look good
just because you can't understand it
doesn't mean it necessarily does not
have a valid outcome or you know can't
be used and I think that what we need to
do is correct large data sets and that's
why I'm hoping microdose not me is going
to give us an enormous amount of data
then that clinicians can harvest from
and going we didn't anticipate this and
like these meta studies about partnered
partner violence when if your partner
men had tripped on mushrooms they were
less prone to violence that was signal
from the noise how many other signals
from the noise of these big big meta
files that we can we can pull out then
we can get serious scientists to do
really carefully control clinical
studies to be able to see this and then
and then how do you combine them and
there's this it's a whole new landscape
that gets away from single molecules and
into the complexity of nature that we
can build upon navigating to that place
is going to be a challenge there's no
doubt about it but I think we're smart
enough now we have enough computer
technologies and diagnostic tools that
we should begin on that voyage today
[Applause]